he is literally Hitler I mean literally
our babies take it two feet over you're
blocking the TV
hey okay when dealing with this whole
Weinstein drama I've always this I don't
want to attribute to collusion what can
be attributed to incompetence but with
the Weinstein in Hollywood sexual
assault situation a sexual assault
situation at large so the question of
the day are we at a point where the
preponderance of evidence leaves no
other option at this point I you would
have to believe incompetence on such a
massive scale it almost seems less
realistic what do you think I would
genuinely like to know we're going to go
through some of the worst offenders
before I get to this let me let me set
this up okay everyone's a hypocrite
everyone in this room is a hypocrite if
you have any standards at all you're a
hypocrite that's that's not what this is
about no the difference is Hollywood
gives themselves awards and they laud
themselves with praise simply for their
pearl clutching hypocrisy their virtue
Singh and the ultimate irony is they're
the worst hypocrites which is really
hard to do when you have absolutely no
stations at all like your high jump is
already below knee level
and they're missing it so this is what
it is
everyone's a hypocrite I get that you
can point that out to every single
person but they don't all make livings
as hypocrites that's the issue can you
believe this scumbag is our president he
is literally Hitler I mean literally are
they take it two feet over you're
blocking the TV
I mean it's the Christian Right taking
the high ground and then voting for this
guy that's just these tweets but I know
they're a pot that hypocrisy knows no
bounds we should find that too horrible
to air but we're hypocrites yeah ruin so
many films that were family favorites
let's uh let's go through the worst
offenders here because I again and then
we can tie to or look at Hollywood at
large first off okay right off at Meryl
Streep Meryl Streep very close to
Weinstein talked about being close to
wine sees a matter fact called him god
and one of her acceptance speeches I
just want to thank my agent Kevin
and God Harvey Weinstein hello didn't
make her from the rib of man he just
raped her yeah and then she went on say
that she had no idea she claims
regarding his sex scandal she had no
clue okay again let's let's do not
everything nothing has been proven yet
okay a lot of this is alleged but here's
the deal with Meryl Streep why don't I
tend to believe her because even if she
did know that Harvey Weinstein was a
sexual assault multiple time felon she
she doesn't have a problem with it we
know beyond a shadow of doubt she has no
problem with sexual assault as seen by
her saying she felt sorry for multiple
child rapist Roman Polanski for him
being in jail and she gave him a
standing ovation at an awards ceremony
the Oscar goes to Roman Polanski
[Music]
now it might seem like that's bad
considering that he anally raped a
thirteen-year-old girl on quaalude my
someone would say that's look behind you
there is the line but everyone's line is
different here's the real here's the
real kicker it wouldn't be as bad if she
weren't traversing the country and in
every single speech decrying bullying
taking this pseudo moral superiority at
any opportunity possible disrespect
invites disrespect violence incites
violence when the powerful use their
position to bully others we all lose
does rape fall under the bullying
umbrella in this scenario
that's what they always do they always
say what they should say to the person
giving them gold and fame to just some
other guy right yeah it's like this miss
message by the way it's like it's not
for you Harvey don't consider yourself
this MIT but about the powerful but no
Harvey you're good you're good just have
to say this to the room here's the next
one that really bothers me Gwyneth
Paltrow so what if Paltrow has now come
out and I know people say were your
victim-blaming I get if they're a victim
of sexual assault absolutely they have
proof they should be heard but there are
two separate issues so Gwyneth Paltrow
claims that Weinstein made unwanted
advances in her leading up to this the
film Emma and allegedly Brad Pitt knew
knew about it and confronted him about
it very very meekly but here's the thing
at this exact same time she was publicly
thanking Weinstein in acceptance
speeches I would like to thank Harvey
Weinstein and everybody at Miramax Films
for their undying support of me here at
this point she's no longer just a
self-serving hypocrite she is that but
she's acting as an active recruiting
tool for Weinstein if you are being
raped if you're being sexually assaulted
behind the scenes now you're a victim
but there is some culpability if you're
going on up to an awards show and you
know that girls from across the country
are watching the glitz and the glamour
and these glorious actresses and I'm
looking up to Gwyneth Paltrow and her
homemade $95 dinners that you can make
to because she's just like you and
you're watching saying oh well what do I
need to do what what did Gwyneth Paltrow
do Oh Weinstein was the one who gave her
a leg up she is acting as a recruit
tool for other horse it's called
vouching for someone exactly like it
like if a mechanic breaks my car and
then I just go to a friend and go you
got to use this guy and then their cars
broken he's like hey thanks a lot man
except you escalate that to rape yeah
your guy thanks your guy over there at
maitus put his what is in the tailpipe
of my car yeah I don't even know how he
expected that to help you're the one
thing to that really really I find odd
not a single ass-kicking from a husband
or boyfriend when Weinstein not one like
not a single husband her boyfriend came
forward and kicked his ass when I read
that Brad Pitt confronted Weinstein oh
man oh so Weinstein has been shot once
no oh did you do this well huh
please don't do that but I do hope you
you give me enough shame on you
and from someone who's been in this it's
like the thing that Hollywood laugh will
do that if she just didn't say he was
great that absence of praise or absence
of condemnation mengapa sit like for me
it was I wouldn't attack Trump voters
right and so people that that silence
like when you see people in Hollywood
that don't talk politics typically
people yeah they start assuming you're
conservative and it's the same thing
with her if she didn't thank Harvey
Weinstein they would be like you better
thank Harvey Weinstein or else it's
obvious that like you're revealing that
he's a scumbag exactly yeah that's an
important point a lot of people don't
necessarily know the politics behind the
scenes and you better thank Harvey
Weinstein it would been it's a it's I
was surprised a story broke well
everyone's known that for years it turns
out there's actually there's more
evidence and accusations here now more
people coming forward that's why it
isn't of course by the way with Gwyneth
Paltrow of course all of this with
Gwyneth happened while she was
championing feminist causes like the
gender pay gap because she's a strong
feminist who praises the people who
commit sexual assault let's move on to
Tina Fey hos hos want money yo they want
them if we say that that's considered
sexist if Harvey Weinstein says that
it's considered foreplay Tina Fey knew
all along and you look back you can see
Seth MacFarlane's joke you can see these
little cues that everyone knew she knew
all along about Weinstein's debauchery
she had a sketch 30 rock it was titled
Jenna turned down Harvey Weinstein three
out of five times roll clip don't duel
with Jaden
you don't want to miss what we're down
oh please I'm not afraid of anyone in
show business
I turned down intercourse with Harvey
Weinstein on no less than three
occasions out of five it sounds like
it's a well known secret it's it's held
normalizing by the way well that's the
thing they keep accusing us for
constantly that's what they do in
literary term it's also foreshadowing
yeah shadowing by the way then Tina Fey
noted feminist and non comedian in chief
went on to tell a college-educated white
women who voted for Trump that well
first off sheet she chastised them and
then told that they couldn't look away a
lot of the selection was turned by
whites at college educated women who now
would maybe like to forget about the
selection and go back to watching HGTV
and I would want to know no silly middle
American women because it doesn't affect
you this minute but it's gonna affect
you eventually what what about what
about being mounted haha that affect me
right now might not affect you right now
are you watching a GTV what about your
guy who raped me could someone consider
I mean I don't even necessarily think
that that's affect by association I
think it's directive because he was
inside of me against my will Tina Fey
strong feminist this is the would again
have a great but they make a living off
of their hypocrisy the huge component to
Hollywood is giving yourself an award
and a huge component to getting an award
is speaking out politically and a huge
component to speaking out politically in
Hollywood if you're gonna be taken
seriously is simply to vilify middle
America let's go this is the final a
trifecta we had to wrap them all up in
one the worst offenders Matt Damon Ben
Affleck and Jimmy Kimmel okay those are
probably the closest people to wine wine
some you go back to Good Will Hunting
Matt Damon responsible for the Ben
Affleck now according to Sharon Waxman
who wrote an expose on Weinstein in 2004
again this is alleged but Matt Damon
made a call demanding that the story be
spiked and then she said the story was
stripped of any reference to sexual
favors or coercion and buried on the
inside the culture section and obscure
story about Miramax firing an Italian
executive so this is something that
journalists have been trying to expose
for a while it's just something that
several people have notice matter fact
rose mcgowan called out Matt Damon
asking what it feels like to be a
spineless profiteer which he is now this
is no one we get it not people aren't
huge fans of Matt Damon but at this
point this is trending right everywhere
Matt Damon is running Ben Affleck right
now because people looking into it so
Jimmy Kimmel created a segment from it
was trending on youtube today
Kimmel now the guy who cried for Cecil
the lion the guy who cried about gun
control healthcare did he cry for a
countless potential rape and molestation
his friends here's Brad it's something
else to note his father's friends by the
way when there's trending when they're
trending videos and in trends on Twitter
okay
and it's really really bad for Ben
Affleck for Matt Damon right now if
you're watching this please just don't
check Twitter it's gonna be it's good
you're gonna have a bad time
um it's sucked in Jimmy Kimmel
deliberately created a video to act as
Damon's PR guy to bury the bad searches
strategically releasing this fluff piece
they're cool okay that's enough we can
shut that up remember when people got
mad at Fallon for not vilifying drone
normalising it's almost like like the
heard of it almost like you're making a
living off of him actually of course
Rose McGowan also called out Ben Affleck
the lesser talented Damon brother as
he's affectionately known so if you're
such thing about Ben Affleck to me
hilarie Burton accused Ben Affleck of
groping her on set of not one trio but
on Tia yeah I think he'll know it's TRL
she won't real actress so she accuse him
of groping her now there's video of this
here's what's interesting to me is uh
okay
this happened but there's also this clip
from a 2004 interview I remember this
clip because I was in Montreal when this
happened this is from a french-canadian
channel and it's been on the internet
for a long time well are usually sure
this was a 92 story
why are you bring it up today
- these are very suspiciously firm to a
Janet Jackson stunt are you wearing your
liberated by all you want to do is have
sex all the time you don't want to talk
you don't want to hold me and the only
time we do get to talks when you think
it's gonna be about sex okay so later
after Gigli how the hell do you have
that kind of confidence have you become
a creepy eighty year old man when you're
a young movie star like that's like how
like the creepiest oldest dude in my
neighborhood batali hey ya boobies that
guy was like a movie star like how is he
so creepy that you only want to talk
about sex huh he went out and he
publicly condemned Weinstein saying this
is this is disgusting and we have to we
have to put more women in positions of
power and I am I am sickened by this a
from Weinstein so he said that then
immediately apologized to to Hillary
saying I acted inappropriately but I
only apologize for that he made this
condemnation wow this here's what when I
see these things I don't just go okay
there's a bad clip of Ben Affleck he
knew that this clip was out there to me
that shows no conscience whatsoever
he was condemning Weinstein hoping that
he would get away with this isn't self
out there it's like that kid everyone
had in the group who you knew you
weren't you were caught and you're all
fasting up but he would still live still
like you're calling does it write you
but yeah okay we did do it we did go
swimming without a lifeguard you know I
didn't Thanks over there it's not even
just lying it's going the other
direction cuz like we're friends you
know that I'm a fairly messy person like
you know I'm just a messy guy that I'd
be the equivalent of not just lying
about that being like yeah I'm not messy
I would then attack you and be like
what's up with all this dust they have
this god complex that they think they're
gonna go do you realise Ben Affleck we
have access to clips from 2004 it's not
Limon trello some internet' and a
sophomore and this isn't by design this
isn't this isn't by happen since right
this is absolutely by design the
Hollywood left like you just said it's
evil and that's why they have disdain
for conservative America you made this
point just evil people hate good people
yeah and and I like the quote that the
line between good and evil goes through
someone's heart because it we we're all
capable of good and evil but like people
trying to be good are seen like and
people that have just accepted this
hedonistic awful existence it like
bothers them too
see happy people they want to make them
miserable like themselves and they want
to just attack them so they have disdain
for Middle America and in basic of
course as Owen points out basic biology
that's why the Weinsteins are some of
the biggest Democrat donors in recent
decades over a million dollars since
2000 it's more than $4 there's multiple
Democrat politicians you know that's one
third of the entire NRA by the way yeah
yeah when it comes to Clinton by the way
she was quicker to come out and condemn
the NRA for what happened in Vegas and
she was Weinstein the big difference is
the NRA didn't put their penis in an
unwilling victim don't take our word for
it you're the politician ISM self this
is possible because of Harvey he is a
wonderful human being good friend the
president thank you for being my guest
tonight and as I said I always learn
amazing things from you true he will
give his penis to anyone who'll have it
and some who won't and then you have
this again we're talking about do you
think again comment I really want to see
your comments on this because I often go
back and forth is everyone incompetent
Barack Obama the same thing with the 77
cents on the dollar do we have to
believe that Barack Obama does have
access to Google he can't actually make
sense of these statistics he can't see
oh that's a basic number that people
just take with the median salary for
women median salary for many dozen take
into account hours or degrees or
experience okay we get it it's untrue do
are we to assume that President Barack
Obama had no clue as to what's been
happening with the Weinsteins and that's
why he sent mallya he was going to send
Mallya over for an internship again no
father's no husband's kicking anybody's
ass when it comes to the wine scene you
can attribute stupidity sometimes but at
some point you have to believe and this
is where I am that Matt Damon Ben
Affleck Meryl Streep Gwyneth Paltrow
Casey Affleck Jimmy Kimmel Tina Fey drew
Barrymore Chuck Schumer Hillary Clinton
Bill Clinton shell Obama Barack Obama
either they're all idiots complete
morons who never knew at all as
marriages I had no idea or they are
actively banding together to sweep evil
under the rug out of convenience
just feels like a bad dream I still
can't believe he's really present like
this video subscribe by clicking the
button it's a circular button now that
says subscribe if not head on over the
Young Turks that's probably more your
speed although they're coming over here
Cinque we know you're here watching I
can smell you from here there's also
recommended video box playing right up
there you can join the monk little otter
with credit.com slash mug Club for daily
content so we're not dependent here on
YouTube shank go/no-go you don't need to
stay here this isn't good for it's bad
for your soul